you're just in time
it's the hourly rapid Arena just started
this is my first
game of the Stream
uh someone wanted me to play a traxxer
so
I will oh let me first make this port
bigger
for geometry
I was doing some puzzles
just a few minutes ago can't play a
Tracker against the scotch unfortunately
if you're white an Italian oh
and if I'm black I'm I may be playing
against an orthos knob
or not
uh this is
forget what we call this line this is
kind of like a scotch Gambit but not
quite a scotch Gambit
thank you Andres
yeah again appreciate the raid shout out
to Andres
um yeah this is still opening prep
it's opening prep I haven't looked at in
a while I'm pretty sure Bishop C5
Bishop C5 one of the main lines
I prepared something very similar for
Canty
yeah this is very typical for
so white essentially got a tempo
taking manage my knight
and I'm pretty sure
this is my exact prep
for candy forget if we actually played
into this line
maybe we played into this line in one of
our games
yeah let me go with Queen B8
so this is a move that
I was like seriously preparing back in
June
uh in preparation for the finals
of the I'm not a GM tournament
the pony very quickly plays Knight C3
which I guess is a little bit concerning
I'm pretty sure the best movies to take
but White's not fearing the Pawn under
attack now I could take the Knight too
but
take the pawn
let's go for this
I'm still kind of relying on memory
take Rook B1 Queen E2
yeah white does seem very prepared here
I think blitzing out every move uh Rook
dates a consideration I know White's
idea is like F5 F6 or F5 E6
so
I have to be cognizant of that
Rook B1 might be an idea I like the
prospect of starting with Rook d8
just to align with the queen apply a
little bit more pressure
if Rook it's imagine Rook fb1 Queen A3
Rook B3 Queen E4
I think it's okay
even Queen A6 I guess when I play Queen
B8 I'm
I'm already committing to
a little bit risky play
like snacking on the pond before getting
my king safe
but it's good to see why it's slowing
down now like if F5 I I think I just
take
just because of the pin discovered
attack
like I have two attackers there's two
Defenders
so
I mean the bishop moving anywhere will
add a third attacker
and the move like Rook D1 looks like it
adds a Defender but after Bishop G4
I'd probably be winning material
I remember analyzing
like B3
there's some cool line
but now I'm forgetting
okay so Rook up B1 I don't really have
another option
Bishop D4 no
okay Rook B3 so now I have two options
Queen A4 Queen E6
I mean queen A4 I think I like a little
bit more
just to pressure the Knight
it's not so easy for a way to exploit
the queen
on A4
that move is very sensible
so creating the battery
also supporting F5
although wait what if I what if I just
taken Bishop
I take and play Bishop E6 I'm attacking
the rook and the bishop
I don't see how white defends
let's go for it
was just a simple tactic
and queen F2 looks nice multi-purpose
move
it's actually really nice my Pawn
controls D3
preventing Rook T3 now I'm likely
winning the exchange white might get
some counter play
for a moment I was thinking F5 is maybe
possible but then I take and then take
the bishop so
um yeah this bishop will probably have
to oh C4 wow
C4 I forgot about
C4 blocks of the rank and the diagonal
but I'm gonna win the pawn at least I
should
Bishop takes C4
yeah let's save the bishop
this actually isn't so simple even
though I'm up two Pawns
um just the nature of the optical Clark
Bishops
wait can I play this move now
take
oh there's a funny line
okay so the same ideas previously
I am I'm hitting the rook and the bishop
and now there's no Miracle C4 move
there is Rook A7
and this is one of the funny lines
but how funny is it I want to take the
bishop
ah it's not so simple
are you Castle first
tick tick
wait a minute if I take the bishop to
watch my time to
do one
oh there's some really interesting lines
let me start by taking the bishop
yeah I was thinking Rook D1 here
if I I mean I could take two and be up a
pawn
and I probably lose a pawn back
so I was calculating this
yeah queen of two I was hoping for E3
I'm now probably castling
hmm
I'm gonna play Queen deep no Queen D5
rookie eight
of
Castle Rook C4
C4 Queen
trying to figure out the lines here
so Rook takes C6 I'm debating between
Rook B8 and Rook 8.
I like Rook be a bit more
because there's backering potential
like there's cool idea to play Queen F2
which doesn't work at all because Queen
F2 Queen G1 never mind
okay so light being cautious it's
understandable
Queen D3 doesn't work
can I play
get away with
I feel like I should play H5 first
let me play H5 first
it frees up like moves like Rook B2
and Rook B2 would have ideas of Rook F2
also E3 E2
at this point it's all about making use
of my past Pawn
and Rook C4 is maybe a little bit
concerning
I really gotta be conscientious of time
I think you are Jordan hi Eric
I'm calculating Rook C4 Queen E3
because Rook C4 Queen D5 there's Queen
E2
and then it looks like I'm losing the
pawn
so the two attackers Rook B1 King H2
Rook C4 Queen E3
and the queen can't actually attack the
pawn
actually Queen E3 ties down the queens
of Defending F4 as well
still down over a minute
a very quickly turning into a Blitz game
a couple people on top have already
played two games
we might see E6
E6 is kind of interesting
I take
in taking later C5
as equal material
white could just take the Free Pawn to
white does
a question between Rook B2
[Music]
I like Rook B2
just focusing on activity
it allows Rook CA King H7 the king
should be very safe there
and time is leveling now which is nice
I think this is the first moment I'm up
in time or up on time in the game
um
most of the schemes especially out of
the opening is
down by a few minutes okay so a
combination of these ideas
not easy to play for lights
like much easier to play for black I'm
also realizing this is an idea Rook D2
to D1
and there's cases later where the H Pawn
can be very useful
and uh controlling G3
and eventually creating some mating
ideas
it's a nice example
um like even in the end game usually
material is a very important
factor in determining who's better but
even an endgame activity of pieces can
uh be more important than material
also the the dangerous or the the
dangerousness
the danger of the like strong past pawns
as well
more about quality over quantity
so King H2 it's a prophylactic move
and if I play this it's like Queen C4
if I play E3
so that opens up the attack against the
pawn
it also opens up this diagonal a little
bit but after you check here
the queen can't attack along the b1h7
diagonal
I do allow this move but then Rook F2
oh Rick F2 I get mated by force
simple oversight
so maybe G6
and G6 E6 oh wow
yeah I've
underestimated the fact that H5 is um
it's just hanging
I have an idea I think I have to play
Rook B7 here or B8
already getting tired
let's play Rook B8
defend the back rank
the idea is to eventually play E2 and
then win a four
another idea is to play H4
okay so rookie one
and play like play this move
and then Rook D1
oh there's almost a really funny idea
I'm not fully seeing what to do I'm
considering G5 here
G5 is insane but
I think I'll play it
I just want to win the E5 Pawn
it looks so counterintuitive
okay so now I can take
here
trade Queens
still not so simple
I don't think I'm better here
looks really close
to being really good
I think I'm gonna win on time though
five
foreign
wait
The Keeney one was the wrong direction
King should have stayed on G1
now G2 is a threat thanks for the Kung
Fu chess games the other day oh my
pleasure any interest in learning proper
black belt technique sometime
Sunday that'd be cool I'll come back
Misha
also known as not Misha
yeah that was a crazy game
um
I guess G5 was a decent practical
decision
uh I think E3 was wrong
maybe a little bit too soon
engine says White's winning
oh I could play this and then this and I
don't have Rook B8
how's that winning though here here
because I have G6
Rook C7 really
ah E6 is coming if I play this there's
Queen A8
that's crazy
okay I could have been losing not an
easy line to spot though
was I ever better
a little bit better after E3 but still
close to a draw
okay it was better earlier
engine like Queen D4
engine wants E3 here
what an epic move just giving up the
rook and then E2 oh that would have been
a funny line
black is meeting by force and E moves
okay
that was a cool game
so I was much better but it was not an
easy uh easy position to win
good game
okay that was the first game of the
tournament
26th Place 183 players
if you want to join this tournament we
do have the join command
uh playing Tola 54.
I saw someone earlier in chat
wait who wanted it was H Posey who
wanted some Italian
[Music]
I saw someone earlier requesting English
but I'll go for Italian
[Music]
I haven't played the Italian in a while
like usually I go for ponziani or my
opponents like play the Petrov or
Stafford
oh thank you Felix
subbing for 18 months
opponent taking time here
I did go through a brief brief phase in
my chess career
um maybe around the time I was like 2100
[Music]
2200 where I played Italian
I was inspired by
Gary Kasparov
does he played Italian in a lot of these
um like simultaneous exhibition games
a nice very like stable opening where
uh it's very rich with middle game plans
also very popular these days at the top
level
[Music]
I'll admit in like very high level play
the Italian it's one of these openings
that kind of scares me because there's
so much Theory
but at a lower level play it's more
about knowing ideas and Concepts
[Music]
yeah castle castle
I assume this is theory
so these days it's very trendy to like
gain's face on the queen side which
maybe I'll go for at some point
like A4 for example
I think A4 makes sense here
like threatening to drop the bishop
and okay black might play A6 or A5
but at least I make black think so A5 it
is
and now
yeah now 92
foreign
probably
we'll see if I can yeah if I can stay
awake
um
I think I'll try
H6
H6 is a move
and play H3
hmm
I don't say that like this idea is very
popular
Italian
like rookie one yeah rookie one neither
one
sometimes called this a Spanish
nightwalk
it was very uh popular in the Spanish
opening but also Italian the Knight
likes to come to the king side
of fun
um at some point I might want to get in
D4 but first things first
get the Knight to a happier place
oh yeah I'm not wearing my own merch
even though there's still a sale on my
merch
coupon code Black Friday for
I think it's 25 off
Bishop E3
take take
I think I'll just play this
I'll leave the tension between the
Bishops
so I'm wearing a bow Tes merch
shout out to Bow teslive they sent me a
whole merch package
yeah so I'm accepting double Pawns
I've seen the structure before in
Italians
and at first it looks weak but after B3
I defend C4 d-files uh half open for me
and these double pawns are actually nice
because I restrict
the the bishop and Knight with the
C3 Pawn
I'd like to go for this idea
maybe H3 first
I wasn't sure about Queen G4 in response
to an H4
but once the knights are here a typical
follow-up is to
start invading F5
now black wants to get the same setup
with the Knights but I think I'll start
with Knight H4
so now I have Knight G6 I could trade
and should be beneficial I could also
consider Knights hf5 or Knight gf5
good evening to Irene
welcome back
oh Faith offering wisdom
the best opening is that which gives you
the best results
which varies
based on who you're playing yeah
hey it's Alice chess welcome back Alice
chess
again if you're just joining this is the
hourly rapid Arena
I'm on a quest to
2600 rapid which
haven't been there in a while
opponent might want to play this
I don't know if I can stop it
I could try to discourage it
I'll start with Queen F3
I'm creating some King's eye potential
yeah let me give you a shout out hope
you're doing well
yeah D5 now I have to figure out
I mean I think it makes sense to take
once
because I don't want block taking on C4
[Music]
someone purchased youth T-shirt oh no my
queen for 20 and donated three dollars
nothing's to the someone
I don't know if um yeah taking kind of
concedes the center
I'm realizing this plan of with Knight
F5
it may not be everything I
I thought
maybe another five
I want to play nine to five it's saying
hf5 takes I have to take on E7
Rook takes takes takes takes everything
kind of simplifies
considering moves like Bishop E3 Bishop
E3 could be interesting
take take
problem is this Pawn is weak in the end
Queen is actually really well placed on
E6 and if I take on Z5 and then play C4
what's going on here
maybe that's the way to go
and take on D5
oh wow takes takes C4 Queen D4 hitting
the rook and Knight
I do have Bishop E3 in that line
okay let's go for this
I mean black has a choice which thing to
take back with
so Queen takes now I'm
I'm leaning towards C4
and we're gonna get a more positional
gain
assuming Queens get traded
yeah for a brief moment I'm scared of
this move but uh after Bishop E3 it's
basically a trade and I think it's a
good trade for white
foreign targets
I actually like the structure even
though it looks like I have some dark
square holes which I kind of do
uh this Pawn is fixed on A5
and my pawns combine better with my
Bishop even though black has a more
active Bishop for now
the hope is that longer term I'll um
I'll have some nice Harmony
I think Bishop B2
there should be two there's E4 ticks
and try Bishop B2
again it's turning into a Blitz game
thank you Super Robot ax
happy 30 months
uh take
yeah I was just calculating the sign
take take
Bishop C3
those might just be equal
I don't think I have a better choice
like I was wanting to play Knight T2 but
then E3
so let's take
and then go back
Okay so
I don't fully know what's going on here
imagine blocks on the take
maybe trade Rooks first
if takes first I don't have to take back
right away like I could start with neta5
oh wow
interesting move
probably a good move too
okay I'm calculating some weird like
rookie three
[Music]
won five games of duck chess today need
to stay warm hey it's Ross of us
and keep it up
I need to uh I need to focus here
it's really not so clear there's a D4 is
a very good move
I think something like
Rook ec1
looks ugly but
at least I leave the tension
I do still want to eventually play
Knight F5
and taking the bishop would have just
allowed the Knight to come in and
annoy me in so many ways
we still might see takes takes Knight D4
and then maybe Rook team one
and F5
maybe I should have just taken the pawn
there's an idea here to play like some
eventual C5 Knight D6
like if rookie five I could have this
choice
it would be committal though
like 93 might be a safer move
and D5 is actually a nice Outpost
now the only problem is if I play Knight
E3 there's Rook G5 happy day
I could take on G2 with the Knight
the U RTR Obama
I'm trying to have a happy game here
up on time
as as we've seen in the past time
uh can be very important towards the end
of these games
especially with no increments
so Rook D2 might be coming
let's start with Knight D5
hey broke G5 I have uh Rook G3
we might see 97
and then some train
yeah
I'm not better here
I don't think I'm really much worse
it should be roughly equal
block taking time
yeah so I think those strategies to put
the Rook on F3
where it defends all the potential Pawn
weaknesses
so rookie two even though the Rooks are
active
well I shouldn't be winning anything
[Music]
there may be some plans to
activate the Rook somehow
C5 maybe hc5 is a nice plan
could maybe play H4
with this
yeah these Rook endings can be very
deceiving so it might look equal
[Music]
and then some small factors can change
the tide
kind of like rookie three
so I want to cut the king off eventually
Rook G5 is a good move
Rook G3
wait trade trade King E7 C5
and I might be you winning the a pawn
oh but then there's Rook T3
oh objectively it should be a draw but I
think I'm gonna win on time
I have this move there there it takes
now
let's activate the king
oh
I'm getting really active with the King
it should have been closer to a draw but
now
and now objectively White's probably
very close to winning more active King
I have to calculate though
I don't know if C5 actually works
C5
wait C5 Rook F5
King C6 takes takes takes no the king's
too close
there's this funny move oh no that
allows Rook D6
wow
I have no way of making progress
again I should have went on time but
I'd like to win some position to
let me play this
I think you 414 Sosa appreciate the raid
if you're just joining I'm about to win
on time
I don't think I'm getting mated
uh C5
opponent was just a little bit too slow
this game
okay final position
it's probably still equal
oh I'm worse here
oh because H3 is hanging
I thought I'd have enough counter play
ever better
that was equal
black played a good game
this may have been like a really clean
game from both of us maybe until the end
yeah background's a good plan like
putting the queen here Knight here and
then preparing D5
things it looks like it was roughly
equal the whole game
man
look at this graph
what is better I was better at the
opening at some point
oh B3 is a cool move to take with the B
Pawn
look at the score I made two
inaccuracies my opponent made one an
accuracy
98 95 percent
okay
a great example of uh a high quality
game that just comes down to time
I generally if I want to win the
tournament I should berserk
I don't think I'll berserk this opponent
I'll play a Sicilian
I've played this opponent before
Knight C3
um
I'll put E6
ah we've gone into I think we've gone
into these lines before
like A6
yeah we've had this before
I think we got a game like very recently
too
I wonder if my opponent has studied this
Knight is four is a fine move
yeah it's one of these openings where I
can
hopefully get away by like pushing a lot
of Pawns early
expanding on the queen side
white played Knight H3 so the Knight
doesn't obstruct the bishop or the
eventual Rook
because there's other cases where the
Knight goes to F3 one idea is if Pawn
takes wow B3
let's say a pawn takes I could play
Knight F6
and B3 I want to hold on to the pawn I
mean there's Knight G5 coming
maybe I'll just play this
I'm leaving tension
trying to provoke E5 I could have spent
a longer time trying to calculate like
takes kind of takes Knight G5 and 6
Queen E2 calculating it now
isn't the most efficient
but Knight F6 was a more intuitive
decision because it seemed like White's
moves were easier in that line compared
to this line where because there's
tension white has to decide whether to
commit to E5
which the opponent does
also takes Okay so
the structure Knight C6
this resembles more of a French
this structure is very common for French
and one nice idea is 97 Knight F5 H5 now
this move would be terrible in in Bug
House
if the opponent has a knight to place on
D6
thankfully the Knight can't move like um
I was going to say like a camel but not
even a camel can move like that
camels move like this yeah the Knight
can't teleport
so D4
I want to start with Knight of five
if G4 I take
it's interesting play Rook C8 first too
actually no G4 Knight H4
let's start with this
yeah there's cases where I don't need to
play H5 immediately because G4 oh I also
have an 83.
I was gonna say G4 Knight H4
is a typical idea
but Knight E3 is
an even stronger idea
but generally later like H5 is a nice
way to just ensure the night's not
getting kicked
like maybe now I'll throw it in
because G4 and H4 Bishop H1
not sure how to assess that
another option is the Playbook C8 G4
take
um
and maybe I will play Rook c8s
the GeForce came middle for white
and there's cases like G4 I'll decide
between this and this but then later H5
can be a nice move
yeah it's nice having a night bishop and
Rook all supporting the pawn
imagine at some point light will
decide to take
but whatever it takes first I probably
take with knights because I want the
bishop landing on C5
there's even cases later like after I
play Rook CNN I might be threatening
take
take take take take and then take on C2
oh yeah my Peak rating I could check
real quick
that was my opponent takes her time
actually never mind Peak rating is like
around 26.60
in Rapid
wow so if I unpause I think I should
just ombus on it like
no other move really looked attractive
there
okay now
now if I take Bishop takes
a train
feels close to winning something
taken but the queen on A5
you can take twice on D4 and play Knight
C5
and play Bishop C6
Bishop D6 is kind of interesting
a lot of G4 take take
huh
thing is I don't know if I want to trade
off this bishop
it could be useful later
let's go for this
I think this this move poses some
questions for whites
because the idea is to take and then
take and then
with the light removed and the line
after takes takes takes without Bishop
C5 winning the queen
ing the queens of the king
and that's the same case of Knight
Retreats and I take on D4
so I was looking at lines where white
plays G4
and then it gets interesting
I was calculating G4 take take and then
not take first but take on a four first
and take
take
and then the queen can't take I mean
there'd be a five there
but that should be fine for black Bishop
C5
Queen H4
okay time management is much better this
game
yeah it's important to keep pressure on
the pawn
like another idea is to take and play uh
Queen B6
if I want to keep building a pressure
I think you rule Bryce the first time
Brian
okay so white plays G4
and now
I could take first but then takes it's a
little bit murky
start by taking
[Music]
and those other line takes takes Queen
takes is possible because after he takes
the queen can take back
but then I have Bishop C5 check
Zoom King each of one
[Music]
oh that move I didn't see
I guess it's just a trade
I want to be fancy here though I want to
play like Knight B5
hit the bishop
seems really close to working
I might just play Knight B5
like move first and think later
there's a type of move that after it
takes I take the bishop the knight's
still just sitting
a Sitting Duck
in front of my face
foreign
material somehow there
I'm gathering takes takes uh Queen C2
oh that's a move too
D4
I could take the bishop in Bishop C5
position that looks really nice
let's go for this I also have Bishop
before
pinning the night
yeah I want to leave the King on G1 like
Bishop C5 would give white time to move
the king to a safer place
so I'm trying to generate tactics first
against the Knight
and then maybe later like play Queen B6
check
or like if the queen moves and there
might be Queen G4 hitting or queen H4
hitting G4
not to mention D4 is a a nice looking
resource
which I think just wins material
the queen can't take the pawn because
the PIN
and the Knights also pinned to The Rook
I'm offering the bishop trade
one way to try and remove one of the the
main Defenders the White's King
oh there's a question about drawing
arrows
yeah usually like if I'm playing a game
and not streaming I never draw a hose
but I draw arrows mainly so people can
follow the calculations
um
let's take
Stephen gray welcome avoid driving and
or operating heavy machinery with a
Sitting Duck in front of your face oh
yes
in front of your face or on your face
thankfully my face is pretty well
protected right now
wait a minute
what did I do
I just missed my chance to
oh actually 94 was a fine move
if I take there's wait I didn't realize
a
the nature of that situation
I was just so focused on how comfortable
my face was
and it should still be good though
like
take on C1 and just Castle
[Music]
or maybe like Bishop C3
huh
maybe H5 first
I'm not sure what to do
take take
he tried first looks like a nice option
keeping the pressure
I think I got too relaxed
I just assumed I was winning material at
D4 and then Knight E4 is a nice resource
on the plus side I'm up on time White's
still under pressure
has some issues to solve
I'm trying to activate this Rook without
even moving The Rook
just by getting rid of this Pawn
and if takes and I can take take and
then take
wow F5
okay how scared should I be
I think I'll start by taking
actually I could take the Rook first
huh that's getting spicy
I just want to take the pawn and then
take the other Pawn
let's start by taking
this Pawn is at least for the next few
moves very poisonous because of Bishop
C5
Queen takes G4 so I have this move
Bishop F1
foreign
spicy and poisonous
yes
don't make for great qualities of a
tasty food
might depend on the spice level though
let's start with the queen C1 and it's
improving with tempo
play this move now
the problem is a pawn is hanging too
King
and Knight C5 is a move
I mean queen H6 was kind of my D or my
backup option
I think I'll play this
not proud of it
but it ties down the bishop to defending
the Knight Knight's pins of the pawn I
defend this and this
this I still have visual C5 most
Europeans considered tomatoes to be
poisonous until the 1800s wow
okay
I wonder who is a brave European to try
a tomato and realize it wasn't poisonous
um
if I take and then take
I think that's okay don't mind the queen
dragon
all right take they're a Nightshade many
of which are poisonous oh really
that's probably good to know
okay it's turning into a bowl game again
yeah I would imagine
not the non-poisonous to me that last
person was wrong you can eat Nightshade
it's fine wait really
wait I don't know what to believe now
maybe I'll just stay away from tomatoes
and tomatoes
I play D3
deflect the bishop
no that hangs a bishop
my doing
smooth
let's play this move
I have to think about the position and
not tomatoes
or tomatoes or poison
[Music]
okay opponent took my poison Bond
Queen G6 is one check and then King d8
The King will find safety eventually
D3
that was a cool game
uh let's play this
I would never lead you astray Eric well
almost never almost Maybe
okay
that makes me trust you again maybe
good game Newton
yeah 94 is a good move
I'm not sure if I've
had something better
let's see
engine calmly wants Bishop B7
yeah Bishop B7 is nice
and maybe just Queen E5 yeah Queen A5
next okay
big game
okay playing tatet we played before
oh we play the game where a Tata just
resigned
uh that wasn't really a game
uh
let's mix up the opening a little bit
going into a pierce
okay let me play Super aggressively
I think this is known as the Austrian
attack
some idea to play E5
before black and play E5
oh yeah if you want the tournament link
we do have the join command
that will get nightbot to share the link
yeah I just want a castle
enjoy the
the center the space development
a file
yeah B5 looks playable but I think
allows me to win a pawn because eventual
pin
okay now 94 looks really nice
yeah this nice combination of uh
of pieces in the center
play C3 although C3 is not really
necessary
Bishop G5 first
hmm
or Knight G5 first
I mean Knight G5 first
that's the type of move that I'm just
trying to go for for the kill
as quickly as possible
the point is after H6 I play Queen H5
takes takes and it kind of feels like a
Greek gift
where the Knight can't really access F6
and queen H5 is a massive threat here
to attack both of the pawn targets
along with a rook oh shwarma says you
should host another Stafford Gambit
tournament
yeah it's been a while since I
even created my own tournament
it's also been a while since I've done
like a custom thematic tournament that
would be fun though
I've been playing so many of these uh
hourly rapid arenas
it's been a nice way to settle down
after a long day
I'm two points away from 2600.
I think I'm still
not gonna make it even if I win this
game
okay
oh no my Bishop
someone call an ambulance yeah this is a
a raging attack
because we have H6 I played Bishop D3
the thing is after Knight B6
the the queen defends F7 so I couldn't
take on that seven immediately
but here there's some funny lines I mean
wow F5
look at this move
Queen G6 takes takes it looks working
so it takes takes
and The Rook would have to move
it's not over immediately if that
defends properly
but it's very close to being over I see
some uh some opening requests in chat
Smith Mora
and some people might just want to see
me play Crazy habits
Robert E suggesting to host a beach cafe
tournament oh dear
it would be fun to host a tournament at
a beach cafe
or just go to a beach and
have coffee
or tea
okay after Rook F6 is a question do I
take the Rook I probably throw in the
check first
because if I take the Rook first Knight
takes and it defends the key squares
let me calculate Rick F6 check here
check
here check
King here
I take take take very close to queening
uh that's a free rook
do I want it
there there there
[Music]
I think I do
and then I'll move back
yeah this is the only legal move
back to G6
and queen H7
[Music]
it's a made in one threats
imagine black will move the bishop
it's either that or resign or Knight F6
and I take
I think this is this will be my first
game
berserking and hopefully winning
I still don't see the horse meat though
but I'm any more material
the king's gonna run only these squares
and I have seven probably
you have King d807
King Yellow check again
check
I don't have Knight of seven
C3 is kind of a Savage move
you're traveling the bishop
in too many ways it's ways to win here
I mean C3 is also in the mission that I
didn't see how to
immediately Checkmate the king
oh the rook's defended
a very clever
so I'll check and take the bishop
ah where's my win I could check him in
the night
or I could check and then win the queen
that's off work
I'm just winning so much material it
should be made eventually
okay hey I gained one rating point
okay
25.99
13th Place
yeah I'm still very far out of first
but very closely I think 2600
again I could show oh no new games
starting
[Music]
at some point I'll show my reading stats
but
priorities are
probably now is taking down bunny cubes
um
there's been too much mention of
Stafford gamut in chat I have to at
least attempt one oh bunny cubes is in
chat oh uh if you heard what I just said
uh maybe you're ready for it
hello to bunny cubes
yeah generally I don't mind if my
opponent's like
watch the stream it's good practice to
mute the stream while playing me but
generally when I'm like talking through
positions I have it in the back of my
mind that my opponent might be listening
so
um
there's not too many cases where the
pawn can actually take advantage of what
I'm I'm saying
that's a good move I'll play H5
um Bishop B6
foreign
has done their work
in the Stafford I think it's already
like Bishop F6 it looks it looked like a
way of simplifying
but
it's already a little bit questionable
for white
because of this pressure
that's Castle
wow F3
if I play
oh there's too many ways to have fun
here
I'm debating
so many fun looking moves I have to move
a little bit faster though
Chuck take away casting rights I think
it's worth it
and then just return
foreign
chat
no mercy here
I want to play a five
well let's just return
actually
let's move to
in this move
ensuring that um
yeah the Bishops control a lot of
squares
I didn't want to play Queen F6 on loud
F4
okay here I can take the pawn
there's Rook B1
it's actually not so simple
feels like it should be simple
I have Queen F2
it could be one Bishop E5
I should take
[Music]
oh there there
objectively I don't think I'm so much
better here
I'm playing still play Bishop D4
and go back to B6 yeah there's some
pressure
but I've won the pawn back and
yeah there's uh
I think full control
we'll just have to watch out for B7 it's
a little bit tender and also watch out
for my time
maybe A7 as well
like we might see Queen C5 here
Queen C5 if I play King B and I lose the
pawn
and there's a few ways to attack A7
wait and we'll try to do off your queen
C5
B6 I loses C6 Pawn
A6 Queen A7
I wonder if bunny cubes is still
listening
as one of these moments where I I
suggest the move for the point
and if they are listening they have a
choice to make
yeah this bishop on F1
not sure how it's gonna
find a happy life
A3 wow
unexpected I guess maybe defending
against
some move that I wasn't planning to play
but
it's a safe move puts the ball in my
court I'll play F5 here
I'm trying to Chisel away White's uh
Pawn Center
the threat might be to take and then
take again
oh
okay it looks like the board was set up
wrong queen and the king and queen are
switched
let's not trade Queens
this doesn't happen too often
there is a period where Magnus Carlson
was playing Central opening
where he would like
switch the king and queen within the
first few moves
oh yeah Shawarma knows what I'm talking
about
yeah maybe actually Queen E7 would have
attacked the pawn but a lot of this
a big question well I gain a reading
point if I win this game
if I lose this game how many rating
points do I lose
no on other sites like it tells you
before the game starts
how much rating
you'll gain or lose depending on the
result
okay I'm thinking taking makes sense C5
makes sense
idea C4
you will lose more than one if you lose
Stephen gray is about to lose 45k
Channel points
didn't you lose like 40K Channel points
the other day
or believing in me
I hope you still believe in me
I'll try and keep your channel points
safe
uh
let me take first
F takes I take here if H takes I also
probably still take here
foreign
's pinned and this Pawn is tied down to
defending G4
so neither Pawn can really take
that move I forgot about
I played this move
interesting pressure Happening Here
thank you
I do have to watch my time
takes
beating what to take with
take take
it looks good
[Music]
how to do this though
take your
just play this
I gotta say real focused I can't get too
much lower in time
I should have considered taking on B1
first
but I still have a double threat
I like the bishop here
attacks defends
there's really not too many ways for
light to defend
against both rats
that's a move
this move
it's a cool move
completely unnecessary move but it's a
discovered skewer
it's a disco skewer and if takes I have
a pin
it still takes a lot of work to win
though
28 seconds
but it should be enough time
because I started advancing the Pawns
should have played this move
why am I thinking
lots of board geometry here oh
rookie three I could have like
tragically pre-move that
that could have been really bad
a few takes I play this
okay
not stalemate
got the job done
wasn't uh
wasn't the smoothest got kind of low on
time there
good game bunny bunny cubes
back to tournaments
top 10.
a leader is kind of running away with it
I've sort of berserking
if I would need
like four more games
four more berserk wins
is there even time for that there is to
have to average six minutes a game
but you imagine like this person is
going to get more points over next
25 minutes
taking time to get a game too
oh playing Newton okay I'll berserk
haven't lost to youton
I assume we've gone into this before
you didn't seems prepared
okay
I'm sure we've run into this before
I'm generally happy to answer the sign
E4 is a plan
E4 B4
maybe this move
and Bishop D3 first
I'm actually not sure of the correct
approach here
I shouldn't be taking too long
I'll start with Rook G1
that's really here I play Bishop E5
so I want to yeah I want to get ready
for E4
not too scared of Knight C4 I think I
just take
B4 just an E2
I see one's very typical
Knight C4 I can take the pawn
really
okay so I want to pawn and I got a pawn
I don't even know what we call this it's
not even the tetris piece
on caterpillar
Pawn slinky
zigzag formation
okay so I'm threading this
also this is a nice idea
five is an idea I'm also uh ready to
take if Knight C4
calculating a weird line yeah I'm kind
of using take take 96.
but then my knight gets trapped in the
end
so it's probably not worth it
maybe just Bishop D3
dependency file
but then
hmm
what if I play E6
tick tick tick I think I will play E6
and pieces are just set up really nicely
for it
and I really don't mind the trade
I'm saying goodbye to my Pawn
what does chat say Pawn Sawtooth Pawn
lightning bolt Pawn chain yeah that's
technically a pawn chain
upon stairs tachinko ponds Pond camel
Pawn snake Pond zipper upon ladder
based
I like Robert E's
word just based
I'm based Pawns
okay so that's actually a fair move I
think I just take though
and now G6 was very tender
so it takes I take if King takes
wow I guess I'll take
about two pawns now and having the
attack King H7 doesn't really help
we do see C5 but now 96
hitting the queen Bishop's pinned I have
to be careful about weird
things against B2
but if needed I always can simplify in
G7
that's a move
can I take on
C5
I want to play Queen
C3
between c394
okay we'll play Queen C3
that probably wasn't necessary this gets
a little bit weird
it's okay I think hopefully
trying to figure out what's going on
here
take there there
just take on
yeah this really wasn't necessary
yeah I think it's okay like 94 I played
this
Rook B2 King C1
it's murky
I'm just not seeing blacks follow up
after King Z1
because this is a massive threat
has a nice coordination Rook defends a
knight everything's attacking G7
there's not a great way for black to add
another attacker
like there's King h8 but then I just
take should get the job done
yeah I guess that line like okay so Rook
B2 King C1 King h8 that I take there's
Queen E6 but then Rook GA King E7 Bishop
D3 King H6 Rook
uh Rook h a organs Queen G5 maze
yeah this move is basically abandoned my
king but my king confeder itself
it was raised to defend itself
and the queen is going to battle
yeah there were probably cleaner ways to
get the job done
like especially after this move
by King C1
this is Once by Chuck
okay I got scared for a moment
because there's an idea
it doesn't work but there is an idea
Rook B1
takes Queen B6 but and then I can move
the queen back
I'll be up material there
okay GG hey I broke 2600. let's go
good game U10
now can I can I somehow crawl my way
crawl my way claw my way
to first place
still very far away
whoa what was this game
looks like first place is gonna lose I
mean this is tricky though
ah
I would need at least three more games
okay it was working again
uh Budapest Canada time
risky opening against someone who's
decently high rated
but I'm trying to be aggressive
this is actually a really nice line for
bullets or Blitz
rapid maybe my opponent will have time
to figure things out
but um
yeah there was a brief period where I
was
playing this line in classical games
when I was rated around
like 2 000 at least U.S rated
I had some fun games with this
so one of the points is if takes I play
Queen F6
that's usually how most games go
objectively this isn't a great opening
but practically it can
can lead to fun positions like E6 is
already
I think now preferable for black
maybe this move
yeah let's start attacking
so there's pressure against the bishop
the pawn the other Pawn G5
G5 H5 is an idea
A3 is a good move
considering G5 first
[Music]
um
okay now this
allowing 94 but then Queen B2
if B4 I'm I'm wondering about Bishop E3
takes takes
my idea would be like Queen C1 Queen A1
Knight C2
as a question of my neck gets trapped in
the end
because in the very end I have like A5
takes takes a file opens I probably
saved the Knight
okay we don't have that
H3 is respectable
sacking probably doesn't work
ah now 94 is coming
I mean do I dare sack
I could play actually I could play this
in this
let's go for it
was not my first
intention
but I didn't want to play 95 and block
the queen
the White's getting some initiative here
but if I get one more move in then I can
maybe get back the initiative
C5 is almost trapping the bishop and
then take take and
have some options
oh we might get this idea again
like Bishop Bishop H2 take
take take hit the queen
Queen A4 Bishop D7
24 even B5
Queen C1
wait so tick tick
there King gets us King gets to see one
I don't think I saved the Knight
we got two pawns on a rook for it
94.
I play Queen B2
this feels irresponsible
also feels kind of fun
so I'm still threatening this
I am sagging the g-pawn
if what he wants to take it
a very confusing position but
it looks fun
if Bishop H2 then
I probably go over this line takes takes
takes because all I have Knight C2 is a
threat
along with attacking the queen Rook B1 I
take and then defend my queen
C1 immediately
I'm probably okay with probably just
take take and H6
the bishop pair
there's F6 as well
yeah this will just be a longer game
probably conceding the bishop Perry soon
95 Maybe
take
I'll start with taking
I don't want to allow
easy move
other king E7 just connect the Rooks
now 95.
hmm
what's my plan
not sure what my plan is but I have to
move quicker
I take
oh lights wants to play C5
how about D5
D5 take take
she looks playable
my pawns make sense on light squares
to compliment the bishop
this might be the last game that counts
for the tournament for me
the pawns are very much complimenting
the bishop
played D4
and D4 actually looks really nice
because I'm about to get a wooden Shield
have to make xqc proud oh didn't see
that move though
if I take
a sack
that's a really good move
if I play D3
[Music]
okay here's my idea oh it looks so ugly
the idea is after B6 I play D3
I'm not sure what's happening here
very strange position
so Bishop D1 or Bishop H5
and B6 is going to be loose
foreign
[Music]
I just want to take that
play this first
take
and start taking something
Bishop d6's idea
well like B5 next
foreign
oh no
he's not expecting that move
no
uh
good game
let's run to the corner
uh what to do
uh had some chances there
oh no my reading
oh no my tournament finish
uh pairings are closed now
while the game's endings
yeah well I played well to like just
keep things going
even though still in control
yeah like I was expecting Rook T3 so I I
kind of semi-premoved King C2
um
with Rook C4 I guess that's a tricky
move because if I play C4 Rook C5
I'd have to like play Rook B5 here
I probably should have anticipated that
I mean maybe I could just get away with
B3
B3 work let's see
I Rook B5 is best B3 is still playable
I'm getting the pawn to B2
that's a fun opening to play
I don't think I've ever encountered E6
I played this
a bunch of times on the chess
a decent win rate
yeah the best move is to take
but if white takes son after Queen F6
um
I think I have some YouTube videos where
I feature this line
uh it's not even like that bad
objectively
and uh yeah white has to be like very
very accurate to secure an advantage
anyway I hope people enjoyed the games
if this goes on YouTube in the future
uh you can watch live on Twitch
and follow on Twitch subscribe on Twitch
if you want to support the content
I have a lot of YouTube content in the
pipeline
question about redactyl
I actually did today's redactol
I got to these redactyl in less than 20
guesses
but maybe I'll um
maybe I'll do redactyl at some point in
the future on stream
good job to this person
you had some long long fights especially
my first few games
uh
some intense end games
so of
uh I think I'll just wrap things up
I'm kind of tired
I'm one minute away from Midnight for me
anyway
um
yeah I'll be back in the future raid is
carrying over send some love to Jerry
and I'll be back soon